el impacto de la guerra golpea hasta las
fibras más profundas de las culturas en
el mundo a las puertas de la celebración
del ramadán países de medio oriente y el
norte de áfrica entre otros se preparan
para adentrarse en un tiempo de
reflexión sin embargo este año el mes
sagrado se vive en medio de la
incertidumbre por el aumento de los
precios en los alimentos básicos a nivel
global a causa de la invasión de rusia
ucrania ambos países se encuentran entre
los principales exportadores de
productos agrícolas
la carne es cara no lo compraremos otra
cosa como los dulces tampoco compraremos
son caros y el aceite ya no lo podemos
usar
en líbano los ciudadanos han reportado
un escasez de trigo mientras que los
territorios palestinos especialmente en
gaza sometida a un bloqueo por el
gobierno israelí desde el 2007 también
sufre estas consecuencias
tenemos alzas de precios especialmente
de la bolsa de harina esto es una gran
crisis especialmente para los panaderos
ya que sufrimos pérdidas que nadie nos
recompensa y no podemos subir el precio
del pan de medio que vive la gente de
gaza entre otras circunstancias
difíciles el mes más importante para la
comunidad musulmana que celebra que el
profeta mahoma recibió la primera
revelación del corán está ahora
atravesado por los defectos de la guerra
pero incluso en contextos tan complejos
las tradiciones se mantienen firmes